hello everyone welcome to part 5 of our
series on nlu and ir
this screencast will be the third among
three of our videos on neural ir
in the previous screencast we discussed
learning term weights as a paradigm for
building neural ir models that are both
efficient and effective
we mentioned two such models from the ir
literature deep ct and dr quiri
both of which despite outperforming bm
25 in mrr still left a very large margin
to the quality that we see in with bert
we asked ourselves can we achieve high
mrr and low computational cost at the
same time
can we do better
to answer this question let us begin
exploring more expressive paradigms for
efficient neural ir
next paradigm here is the representation
similarity paradigm
in the representation similarity
paradigm we begin by tokenizing the
query and the document
and we feed each of them independently
through an encoder like birth for
example
this encoder is then used to produce a
single vector representation for the
query and for the document separately
so for birth we could take this through
the class token for example and take the
output embeddings or we could average
all the finite layer outputs
once we have those we finally calculate
the relevance score of this document to
our query as a single dot product
between two vectors
this paradigm is very efficient for
retrieval
first each document can be represented
as a vector offline
and this pre-computed representation can
be stored on on disk before we even
start conducting search
moreover the similarity computation
between a query and a document here is
very cheap and that's very efficient
as it's just a single dot product
between two vectors
a very large number of ir models are
representation similarity models
many of those actually precede birth
like double sm and snrm but the last
year and a half we've seen numerous
similarity models based on birth for ir
tests
including s birth orca dpr d birth and
ansi among others
many of these models
were actually proposed concurrently with
each other
and their primary differences lie in the
specific tasks that each one targets and
the supervision approach each one
suggests
so let us delve deeper into a
representative and one of the earlier
and most popular
models among those this is the dense
passage retriever or dpr by carboquin
ital which appeared at emlp just a few
months ago
dpr encodes each message or document as
a 768-dimensional vector and similarly
for each query
during training dpr produces a
similarity score between the query and a
positive passage so that's the relevant
passage we wanted to retrieve as well as
between the query and a few negatives
some of them are sampled from the bm25
top 100 and others are in-batch
negatives which are actually positives
but for other queries in the same
training batch
once dpr has all of those scores during
training it then optimizes a
classification loss namely n-way
classification loss with soft
cross-entropy loss with soft max
over the scores of one positive and all
of these
negatives with the target of selecting
the positive passage of course
dpr was not tested on the ms marco
dataset by the original authors
but subsequent work by chiang guitar
tests a dpr-like retriever on ms marco
and achieves 31 mrr they also then
suggest more sophisticated
approaches for supervision which can
increase this mrr by a couple of points
so both of these demonstrate
considerable progress over the learned
term weight models that we looked at
before like deep ct or doctor queen
but they still substantially trail
behind births much higher effectiveness
so why is that
as it turns out representation
similarity models suffer from two major
downsides when it comes to ir tasks
first are there
single vector representations which
involve cramming each query and each
document into one rather low dimensional
vector
second is their lack of fine-grained
interactions during matching
representation similarity models
estimate relevance as one dot product
between two vectors and as they lose the
term level interactions between the
query terms and the document terms that
we had in query document interaction
models like birth in fact even simple
term weighting models like bm25 or deep
ct had
by design some element of term level
matching there that we lose here
so our next natural question then
becomes can we obtain these efficiency
benefits of precomputation
that we get from representation
similarity models
while still keeping the fine-grained
term level interactions that we used to
have before with a model like birth or
deep ct
toward answering that question
i think it helps to review the neural ir
paradigms we've seen so far
on the left hand side we looked at the
learned term weights paradigm
these models offered independent
independent encoding of queries and
documents which was great for efficiency
but they forced us to work with a bag of
words query that loses all context
and thus were not as competitive as we
wanted them to be
we then explored the representation
similarity models which also allowed us
to compute independent encodings of
queries and documents which again was
really useful for efficiency
but this time we were forced to work
with single vector representations and
we lost our fine-grained term level
interactions
which we intuitively believe to be very
useful for matching in ir tasks
on the right hand side we looked
initially actually at the query document
interaction models like standard birth
classifiers
these offered very high accuracy
but were extremely expensive to use
because the entire computation for one
document depended on both the query and
the document we simply couldn't do any
pre-computation in this case offline in
advance
so can we somehow combine the advantages
of all these three paradigms at once
before we answer that question there's
actually one final feature
one final capability of the first two
paradigms that we should discuss
so query document interaction models
which are quite expensive they forced us
to use a re-ranking pipeline
this is a pipeline where we rescored the
top thousand documents that we already
retrieved by bm25
sometimes that's okay but in many cases
this can be a problem
because it ties our recall to the recall
of bm25 which is ultimately a model that
relies on finding terms that match
exactly across queries and documents
and so it can be quite restrictive in
many cases
when recall is an important
consideration
we often want our neural model that we
trained to do the to do end-to-end
retrieval that is to search quickly over
all the documents in our collection
directly without any ranking pipeline
learning term weights
and representation similarity models
that we looked at so far alleviate this
constraint and this is a big advantage
for them
so specifically when we learn term
weights
we can save these weights in the
inverted index just like with bm25
and that allows us to
obtain fast retrieval
when we learn vector representations it
also turns out that we can index these
vectors using libraries for fast vector
similarity search like face fai double s
this relies on efficient data structures
that support pruning
which is basically finding the top k
matches say the top 10 or the top 100
matches without having to exhaustively
enumerate all possible candidates
the details of search with these pruning
data structures is beyond our scope but
it's really useful to be aware of this
important capability for end-to-end
retrieval
okay
so let's go back to our last main
question can we obtain the efficiency
benefits of precomputation while still
having the fine-grained term level
interactions that we used to have
the neural ir paradigm that will allow
us to do this is called late interaction
and this is something that i've worked
on here at stanford
so let's build late interaction from the
ground up
we'll start as usual with tokenization
of the query and the document
we will seek to independently encode the
query and the document but into
fine-grained representations this time
so as you can see on the left hand side
this is actually not hard as it's shown
we can feed two copies of birth the
query and the document separately and
keep all the output embeddings
corresponding to all the tokens as our
fine-grained representation
for the query and for the document
okay so we're only going to be done here
once we actually close this loop right
we still need to estimate relevance
between this query and that document
essentially we have two matrices and we
need a notion of similarity between
these two matrices or these two bags of
vectors
however not every approach will suffice
we insist that we get a scalable
mechanism that allows us to use vector
similarity search with pruning
to conduct end-to-end retrieval
in a scalable fashion across the entire
collection
in doing this or for doing this it turns
out that a very simple interaction
mechanism offers both scaling and high
quality
so here's what we're what we'll do for
each query embedding
as i show here we compute a maximum
similarity score across all of the
document embeddings
so this is just going to be a cosine
similarity
giving us a single partial partial score
for this query term which is the maximum
cosine similarity across all of the blue
embeddings in this case
we'll repeat this here for all the query
embeddings
and we'll simply sum all of these
maximum similarity scores
to get our final score for this document
so we will refer to this general
paradigm here as late interaction and to
this specific model shown here
on top of birth as colbert
and the intuition is simple for every
term in the query we're just trying to
softly and contextually locate that term
in the document
assigning a score to how successful this
matching was
um let me illustrate this with a real
example from the ms mark marco ranking
development set and i hope it will be
quite intuitive once you see it
at the top is a query and at the bottom
is a portion of the correct passage that
colbert retrieves at position one
because we have this simple late
interaction mechanism
we can actually explore the behavior and
we can see in this particular example
that colbert matches
through maximum similarity operators
the word when in the question with the
word on in the phrase on august 8th
which is a date as we might expect
it matches the word transformers with
the same word in the document
it matches cartoon with animated
and it matches the individual words come
and out with the term released um when
in in in the phrase it was released on
august 8th
in the document
as we might intuitively expect so we're
basically just trying to contextually
match these quiddity terms
in the document
and assign some matching score for each
of these terms
so notice here and and remember that
covaria presents each document as a
dense matrix of many vectors and in
particular one vector per token
and this differs from the representation
similarity models we looked at before
which tried to cram each document into
one vector and what makes this possible
is the maximum similarity
operators that we have on top of these
matrix representations
so how well does colbert do
and how does it do with this gap that we
have here between efficient models and
highly effective ones
well by redesigning the model
architecture and offering a late
interaction paradigm colbert allows us
to achieve quality competitive with
birth at a small fraction of the costs
perhaps more importantly colbert can
scale to the entire collection due to
pruning with end-to-end retrieval
all nine million passages here in this
case um while maintaining sub-second
latencies
um and thus it allows much higher recall
than traditional re-ranking pipelines
permit
all right so so far we've looked at in
domain effectiveness evaluations
basically cases where we had training
and evaluation data for the ir task at
hand which was ms marco so far but we
often want to
use retrieval in new out of domain
settings we just want to throw our
search engine
at a difficult problem without training
data without validation data and see it
perform well
we briefly discussed the air before
which is
a recent effort to test our models in a
zero shot
setting where the models are trained on
one ir tasks a task and then they're
fixed and then they are tested on a
completely different
set of tasks
beer includes 17 ir data sets and there
are nine different
ir tasks or scenarios and the authors
nand and ital compared a lot of the ir
models that we discussed today in a
zero-sharp manner against each other
across all of these tasks
so let's take a look
um
here we have bm25
results results for an interaction model
which is in this case electra which
tends to perform slightly better than
birth for ranking we have two
representation similarity models dpr and
s-bert
and we have a late interaction model
which is colbert
um
the best
in each row in each ir task is shown in
bold and we see that across all tasks
the strongest model at ndcg at 10
is always one of the three models that
involve turn-level interactions which
are electra colbert and bm25
interestingly the single vector
approaches which seemed quite promising
so far
failed to generalize robustly according
to these results
whereas colbert which is also a fast
model
almost matches the quality of the
expensive electra anchor
the results so far where on the metric
ndcg attend which is a precision
oriented metric looks at the top results
um but here i have the author's results
um
after the task level aggregation um
considering recall at 100
and here although
we see that that you know the
the results are rather similar when we
consider recall
but one major difference is that
colbert's late interaction mechanism
which allows it to conduct end-to-end
retrieval
with high quality allows it to achieve
the strongest recall in this case
and so we can conclude basically that
scalable fine-grained interaction is key
to robustly higher call
of course notice that the bm25 and
electron recall here
is the same since electro are just three
scores the top 100 in this case from
bm25
so this concludes our neural ir section
of the nlu plus ir series
in the next next screencast we will
discuss how scalability
with these retrieval models can actually
drive large gains in quality not just
speed
uh which we haven't seen so far except
on the recoil case
and how tuning in neural ir model fits
into a larger downstream open domain in
the liu task